Welcome to Viggo Mortensen!
Thanks.
Tell me, Viggo, how do you promote a film in these days,
you're in Madrid, but one usually travels around to promote a film?
It's difficult. I just returned after
almost a months road trip alone, because I didn't want to get sick.
So it was a long trip, but it was very exciting.
How did you experience driving through Europe now?
It was strange.
People are more attentive to
the fact that life is short.
That ...
That life is frail.
Difficult.
But it's always been like that. Life is always uncertain.
People are just more aware of it now.
And I think that that's a good thing. It's good to face things, I think.
Is that something you yourself have been conscious of earlier?
I've always thought about death, actually.
And that doesn't have to be negative. I can remember that my mother told me,
I must have been two or three years old,
and I asked her after a dog died, and a horse, and some old people I had heard of
in my family who had died, and I said ÇMomÈ
ÇAre you going to die?È
And she said: ÇWhy are you asking that? We're not going to.È
ÇBut I want to know, mom.È
ÇWill you die?È
Then she said: ÇYes. But it's not going to happen now. It'll be a long while.È
And I said: ÇWell, okay.È
ÇAnd am I going to die?È
And she says:
ÇYes. But not now.È
And I said: ÇOkay. I just want to know.È
And since that day
I wake up every day, and that's the first thing I think about.
ÇMmm. Okay.È I wasn't afraid.
But I thought that you just has to do something.
You gotta get going. You have to do things, you know.
So that's what I think about.
But I think that most people don't think about death every day.
And maybe they should.
To appreciate the life that they have.
The friends they have. The possibilities they have to communicate with people in a real way.
If everyone thought about that, there wouldn't be so many problems in the world,
there would be a little more compassion,
and better communication.
Gro, you are the oldest of us after all, what do you think about these things?
I have not thought about death every day in the way he now describes.
And I mean throughout life.
But I have noticed that after I turned 70,
and not before that, I think, but after that
I began thinking in the lines of:
Now there's an era left in life.
How long it is, you don't know.
It can be five years, ten years, fifteen years.
And that kind of thinking didn't occur until I was 70-75.
So, he's special, that one, who thinks about that every day!
Have you thought about where you want to be buried and such?
No.
Do you, Viggo?
You've lived all over the world, you're a man who's
seemingly rootless. Do you know where you want to end up?
Yes, I have thought about it. And I have written it down.
And I might change it, the idea.
But what I want is for my ashes to be spread different places in the world.
Lakes ... Streams ... In the ocean ... Different places where I've lived or that mean something to me in the world.
And I want to put som money aside
for my son, or who it might be, but I think it will be my son,
so that he can ... I've spoken to him about it, and he's ...
He's okay with it.
To take these ashes and spread them out, and he'll have enough money to stay at hotels and travel and such.
There and there and there, in different places.
That's my idea. And that might not be what happens, I don't know. But that's my idea right now.
Let's hope that that won't happen for a long time. We have to talk about your film, which is called ÇFallingÈ.
You've directed it yourself, you've written it yourself, it's
a very personal story.
How did you come up with wanting to write it?
While we're speaking of death ...
I wrote the story ... The idea came
after my mother's death.
After her funeral.
As happens in funerals, you hear a lot of stories about the person who died.
And I recognized some of those stories.
And then there were some new stories.
But even the stories that I recognized were slightly different. It depended on who was talking about my mother.
So I thought it was interesting.
I think that memory or memories
are more a collection of feelings than facts.
So I thought it was very interesting how
it was slightly different depending on who told the stories about my mother.
So I wrote these things down before I forgot them.
And when I had a look at all of this,
I thought: ÇThis is a good story. It could become a good movie.È
And then I started to write ÇFallingÈ.
The story isn't that different from your own family history.
Among other things it's about a dad who
suffers from dementia.
Yes.
You've had quite a lot of that in your family. Has that made you extra worried about the same thing happening to you?
Yes. And I discovered that there's a test you can take
where you can see if you're prone to it.
In your genes or something.
And then ...
There was a friend who told me: ÇYou know that you can find out if you're prone to get dementia or Alzheimer's?È
ÇHave you done it?È
And he said: ÇNo, I don't want to know that.È
And I said: ÇI want that.È
And I went to the doctor and I got a blood test.
And they said: ÇNo.È
ÇI don't think you'll get it.È
And I said: ÇOkayÈ. Although you never know.
I've had ...
I've experienced the dementia process
very intimately.
With both my mother and my father, my step-father, my grandparents ...
And a lot of family members in both Denmark and the US.
So that helped me describe it, the illness, in the movie.
And to create Willis, who is the old man in the movie, who portrays my father in the movie.
And his relationship to his son
and the rest of the family. So that helped me describe that, yeah.
What is it that people don't understand about that illness?
When you've been close to it and helped look after it
you can see that it's mostly those who look after the people who are sick,
who become confused.
It's not them who are confused. But when you watch films about dementia or Alzheimer's
they normally show a human who's very confused.
And ...
And if they show the view point of the sick person
they show a human that's confused.
And that's not my experience.
So I've tried to show that through images and sound
and the actor
his viewpoint.
And Willis isn't confused.
It's the ones who take care of him. It's his son, who I play, and others, who become confused.
But they see what they see and hear ...
And the mistake you can make when you
are with these people
who have dementia is to correct them.
You want to correct them.
For example.
It's very normal that they want to talk about a person who's long gone.
So you'll naturally
want to say: ÇNo, dad. Johnny died 30 years agoÈ.
And if you do that, Johnny dies again for them. And it's terrible.
And if they're clear enough to come out of it,
then they feel really stupid.
That doesn't help.
Who is it that you want to help?
It's not them. It's yourself.
You want your father or your mother or your best friend
as they were before, and that's not happening.
You have to accept what it is.
And for example, if my father has said:
ÇI had breakfast with Johnny today.È
ÇAnd we have a nice conversation.È
I will say: ÇSo, what did you eat?È
And: ÇWas it tasty?È ÇHow is Johnny doing?È
ÇWhat's happening?È ÇNothing is happening.È And he's happy to talk about it. And then it's over.
One shouldn't correct it.
Your description fits very well with ... We spoke to
the Swedish football manager Erik HamrŽn who has a similar experience,
and he agreed with you about this, very recently.
Do you have any close experience with this, Gro?
The case was that my mother
had this increasingly the last seven-eight years of her life.
So I've experienced what he now talks about,
that she thought that my father still ...
She asked: ÇWhere is Gubbe?È
And that was a little difficult because
we then had to say that he had passed quite some years ago.
And I completely understand what he is saying, because you don't have to correct them.
But when you get a question, it becomes a bit more difficult.
But I remember that, that she sometimes asked about her husband.
My father.
Your father was Danish, Viggo, as far as I know he died about three years ago.
And in the middle of your huge career that you have, after all, were you able to be there for him?
Yes.
I haven't made that many movies in the last years because of that.
A movie every fourth year or something like that.
Because I wanted to be with my mother and then my father, who died two years later.
But you can also ... I know that
as the prime minister says, that it's difficult when they ask you,
but you just have to be quick, you just have to improvise.
I can tell you another story about my father, he once asked ...
He was used to saying, he lived in the US for many years.
And normally we wouldn't speak Danish together unless we were talking about something we didn't want anyone else to hear.
Or understand.
A cryptolect!
Yes! But when he got dementia, he began to speak Danish all the time.
And with a strange accent that he must have had when he was young.
A young man, or a boy.
So he was speaking Danish the whole time, and there was a nurse who was with us, and she said in English:
ÇI don't understand what he's saying, he's talking that language again, can you ask him what he wants?È
I said: ÇOkay. What is it, father?È
He said: ÇWe can't let the elderly stand outside in the snow!È
And I said to the nurse: ÇIt's okay, it's not important, I can deal with it.È
ÇWhat are you talking about, dad?È And then I discovered that
continued saying: ÇThe old people are outside in the snow, it's not good.È
ÇWe have to get them.È
ÇThey're at the station. Iustrup station.È
And there was a station until
40 years ago
in Ustrup, but it doesn't exist any longer.
And I knew that there were people in the family who had traveled from an island called Sams¿ and they had taken the train,
a long travel to come visit them.
And they were to be picked up by a horse carriage at the station.
And I said: ÇOkay, dad, I'll be right back, I'm going to pick them up.È
And I went to the kitchen and grabbed a cup of coffee.
And a couple of minutes later I went back to him.
And I thought: ÇEither, he's forgotten it, or he'll ask about it again.È
So I went back to him with a cup of coffee, and he said: ÇSo?È
And I said:
ÇI have picked them up. But they're so tired from the long travel that they've gone to bed.È
ÇThey apologize. But we'll meet them for breakfast.È
ÇCompletely okay. Very good. Thank you for that.È
And then it's over.
But if I had said:
ÇThere's no station in Ustrup and they're dead.È
He would experience that again, and that's terrible. And that's not necessary, that's what I'm saying.
You should improvise, you should be quick.
Viggo, you grew up partly with your father, partly with your mother.
Partly in the US, in South America, in Denmark ...
And you now live with your beloved in Madrid.
Yes.
Has this made you rootless, or has it just made you adaptable, what do you think?
I think that every human being sometimes feels
strange or that they don't belong anywhere.
Even when you've just lived in a village your entire life. So that's just
the way we are. But what I've learned
from traveling so much in my life, is that it's more important how you feel
than where you are.
You can feel at home and communicate with people everywhere.
With all kinds of people
I think, that's what I've learned.
Of course I have special
connections to Denmark, to Scandinavia,
I also have a connection to Norway, I have family there,
who have lived in Oslo and in Trondheim, and I've traveled a lot in Norway,
so I cherish Norway and Norway's landscape,
and I have a strong connection to Argentina, where I lived the first ten years of my life.
And the US, of course, where I was born and where I have family.
But there are many places where I
feel at home.
And I think I can feel at home everywhere, it's possible.
We're speaking Norwegian and Danish and Scandinavian languages here, but does your
personality, and I'll ask Marcus about this as well, but when you can switch languages like this,
does the personality come with? Does the personality change at the same time?
Well, that depends ... I think,
and people have said that to me, that I notice it the most when I write poems
in Spanish or in English, there are some things I can express better.
It depends on what the subject of my writing is.
Sometimes it's easier to express something in Spanish, and sometimes it's easier in English, for example.
But when I speak
Spanish or Italian, for example,
I have this body language. I'm a little more ...
I speak with my hands and things like that, without thinking about it.
And I might do that now as well, when I'm speaking Danish, maybe it's because I grew up in Argentina, I don't know!
But I can tell that
language in some way changes the way I
present myself. I think so.
What about you Marcus? Do you become someone else when you speak English instead of Swedish? Or when you speak Ethiopian?
First and foremost I think it's fantastic what Viggo is talking about because
we need to hear more stories about how we as human beings can fit in almost anywhere.
You can live a full life and you can never judge anyone.
If Viggo hadn't been famous around the world,
who would have thought that he speaks Spanish and understands the culture of Argentina?
Who, when they look at me, would think that I'm rooted in Swedish and that I'm Ethiopian?
You should never judge anyone, and I think it's magical to hear this.
I've lived in seven different countries.
And I was really equally happy in all seven.
I've lived in Japan. I've lived in France. Switzerland, Austria, Sweden, USA.
And you're quite quick to apply yourself.
You want to get something out of the day, you want to learn a lot and you want to be social.
And that's the magic thing about people, we can do that.
When I was 18 years old and in Japan alone,
wow! How would I survive? How would I take the subway?
It took me two days to figure it out, and I loved it!
And I lived in France ...
And we as human beings are quick ... We have a magic,
that we can apply ourselves. And then you also see that
all the other things we usually judge people by, are you Muslim, are you Jewish, are you a Christian,
all of that becomes secondary. It's all about human reaction.
How are we? And how do we communicate with this fellow human being.
So we need more stories like this, and we need to not be afraid ...
I think it's also associated with the fact that Viggo writes and does creative things,
so seeing that you don't have to be afraid of death
is something he can apply to his job.
It's the same with food, to me, food has a spiritual anchoring.
If I'm with my Ethiopian family, where you first and foremost eat with your hands, you offer food with your hands,
that creates a much more reactive and engaging meal.
And if I were to do that with my Swedish family,
it wouldn't be appropriate, maybe.
But it's the opposite, we need to eat more with our hands in Sweden!
You of course have to wash your hands, corona poster.
The more we learn about what other people do, the richer life becomes!
Viggo, your story is both a story about a family, but
it's about a division in a family, really.
And it's also an image of what was your home country before you moved to Madrid, USA.
Am I right about that, is it a small image of a country, in a way?
Yeah. I think that any story about my family in a book or in a movie
can be a reflection ... You can see society in it, you can.
And in ÇFallingÈ you certainly can, because there's conflict and polarization in the family that reflects what's happening in society in US. But not just in the US.
There's something called the COVID-19 pandemic.
But there's also another kind of pandemic.
Which is as old as the human race.
And that's a pandemic that's on the rise sometimes, and it's on the rise right now, and it's the pandemic of bad communication.
The bad communication pandemic.
That's happening now. It's just as high up a problem
and it's not just the United Stated, it's in Europe,
you have people who feel free now to be openly racist and
misogynist and intolerant
and of course, this example is set by our leaders, often.
You know. And they give people permission to behave this way. The problem is that people are unable to communicate well.
And you can look at the conditions in the movie and compare it to what is happening in the US,
and maybe more this year than a year ago.
That's for sure. But I hope that, just as in the movie,
I hope that memories of family connections,
the memory of a time when we could connect,
might help us to reconnect now. This is what happens in the story, with the family.
And I think in society, whether it's the United States or Norway or Denmark or Ethiopia or anywhere,
when people remember,
you know, any country, Argentina, Somalia, anywhere, it doesn't matter,
if people together make an effort to remember moments in their society's history when there was a good communication
and some give and take
then they can re-establish that again.
I'm optimistic in that way.
I think it's always possible to communicate.
In ÇFallingÈ, it's mainly about a father and a son.
And the son is very stubborn.
He wants to communicate with his father.
And the father doesn't want to communicate with him.
Doesn't want to see him, doesn't want to accept him.
And it's possible, even if you're just as stubborn about communicating as the other person is stubborn about not communicating,
maybe you will never have a point of contact.
Maybe you will not find compassion and empathy.
But it's possible.
If you say: ÇForget it.È
ÇThe relationship is over, I'm not talking to you anymore.È Then there is no hope for progress.
The same with different countries,
different races, different religions,
if you stop talking, then nothing happens.
That's for sure.
It's about that for me. And of course you can compare the film to society.
Viggo, your ...
You're receiving the Stockholm film festival achievement award now,
and you're mainly getting that for your fantastic achievements on-screen,
but this time you're directing yourself.
A lot of people remember you from your collaboration with Peter Jackson, who did ÇLord of the RingsÈ.
What's the most important thing he taught you about directing?
What I've learnt is
different from what I've gotten from it.
I've gotten two things:
One thing that every person who participated in that film trilogy got was
more opportunities to find work.
Good parts, good opportunities.
But the most important thing I learned was that
to solve problems.
You know, it was a long shoot, and Peter Jackson had a crew of maybe
700 people, most of them from New Zealand,
who had very little experience in making movies, many of them.
And no experience in making a huge movie like that one.
So they learned as they went.
And there were a lot of problems, as there always is when you make a movie.
And Peter Jackson was amazing in his patience and he was always
working collectively with people.
Found ways to solve all kinds of problems. Even if he had to invent a completely new way of filming something.
ÇWell, it can be done. We'll figure out a way.È
So it was just that there's always a solution
and you don't have to do it by yourself. In fact,
it's always better if you do it as a team, you know. So
that's what I've learnt the most about from Peter Jackson and that experience.
Where will you store your prize when you receive it?
Well, here, in the office in my house, I think!
The prize from Stockholm, the film festival?
It's ... I've seen it before, it's a horse.
Like a ÇDalahŠstÈ.
But it's made from metal, bronze.
It must be heavy, I think.
So hopefully I won't be flying home.
It must be driven by car, because it's very heavy.
You must promise to have it on display!
Yes. Yes. It looks beautiful.
But it's of course wonderful to get recognition for the work I've done throughout the years.
I'm a veteran in that sense.
And it's strange. Because I'm speaking with you as a beginner, a first-time director.
But on the other hand, I'm getting this prize, which I don't know if it's a
hint to say ÇOkay, you're doneÈ!
ÇMake room for others!È
But I'm not done, I'm stubbornly going to keep going.
Viggo, it's been lovely to have you on the show, next time we'll meet IRL as it's called.
Thank you so much, Viggo Mortensen!